you're
becoming quickly becoming more and more
popular
uh speaking about political issues in
part
do you feel a burden
like almost like uh the the prison of
your
prior convictions of having to
being popular with a certain kind of
audience and thereby
unable to really think outside the box i
had
i've i've really struggled with this i
came up in right-wing media
i came up a much more
doctrinaire conservative in my
professional life i wasn't always
conservative we can get to that later
um if you want and i did
feel an immense pressure after jan
after the election by people to say
wanted me to say the election was stolen
and i knew
i had a sizable part of my audience well
here's the benefit
most people know me from rising which is
with crystal and me
that is inherently a left-right program
so it's a large audience so i felt
comfortable and i knew
that i could still be fine in terms of
my numbers whatever
because a lot many people knew me who
were on the left
and if you know my right listeners
abandoned me
so be it i was had the luxury of able to
take that choice
but i still felt an immense amount of
pressure
to say the election was stolen to give
credence to a lot of the stuff that
trump was doing
to downplay january 6th to downplay many
of the republican senators
or justify many of the republican
senators some of whom i know
who objected to the electoral college
certification
and who stoked some of the flames um
that have
eaten the republican base and i just
wouldn't do it
and that was hard man like i
feel more politically homeless right now
than i ever have
but i have realized in the last couple
of months that's the best thing that
ever happened to me
it's freedom it's true freedom i now say
i
say exactly what i think and it's not
that i wasn't doing that before
it's maybe um i would avoid certain
topics or like
i would think about things more from a
team perspective of like am i making
sure
that it's it's i'm not saying i didn't
fight it i still
i criticized the right plenty and trump
plenty before the election and more
it's more just like i no longer feel as
if i even have
the illusion of a stake within the game
i'm like i only look at myself
as an outside observer and i will only
call it as i see it
truly and i i was aspiring to that
before
but i i had to have in a way
trump's stopped the steel thing it like
took my shackles off
100 yeah cause i was like no this is
[ __ ] and i'm gonna say it's [ __ ]
and i think it's bad and i think it's
bad for the republican party
and if people in the republican party
don't agree with me on that
that's fine i'm just not gonna be
necessarily like associated with you
anymore
you